what's up guys Vincent oshana here with
valuetainment I'm here with Marcus
Pittman and Jason Farley uh we're here
at the Turning Point USA action
conference uh can you guys please say a
little bit about yourselves and what you
guys are doing here what company you
represent and what you're going to try
to get out of this conference so we just
launched a streaming platform it's like
Netflix and Kickstarter had a non-woka
baby and it allows the monthly
subscriber to actually spend their
monthly subscription and fund movies and
TV shows and build the community of the
streaming together as a community what's
the name of the what's the name of the
called Lore llor.tv
um and uh we just launched a month ago
okay and uh it's been fantastic that's
fantastic Jason what's about what about
you same same situation yeah well I'm
here mostly because Trump supporters are
more fun
have you have you ever been to a
democratic one of these uh situations no
because I'm not gay
so you've never been to like a DNC
conference where uh would you just like
get the experience I would but I don't
think there would be anyone there on
stilts
I don't think so either so uh so so
shifting gears just for real quick uh
I'm I actually the last guy the whole
cocaine at the White House incident
let's be like they don't know whose it
is secret service has no idea they
concluded the investigation even though
this is the most secure building on the
planet what do you guys think the story
is and whose is it and be honest uh I
think it's either I think it's like
Kamala and Hunter together both of them
they're sharing those hair in it she
does ramble like somebody I'm pretty
sure we've done cocaine guys we're at
somebody's house and it's five o'clock
in the in the morning and they're just
like space and time that's Kamala like
yeah I I mean I was gonna say it was
Joe's but he didn't get any faster so
he's still slow it bothers me because
people are like hey do you think it's
Joe Biden bro if Joe was on coke if Joel
was on blow you would know like that
just this is cocaine speed though that
might be yeah
yeah he's one of those people that's
like no cocaine this doesn't do anything
it's like Joe don't be that guy so you
guys are obviously you guys are
obviously voting for Trump what do you
uh what do you think like the the main
focal point of the presidency is going
to be this year uh uh to uh to get rid
of the corrupt uh deep set what here's
my thing but do you think that he can
they they interviewed that uh
Christopher Ray was getting interviewed
the other day all all uh nothing salad
no I can't talk about it this is under
investigation do you think that if if
elected Trump will be able to get in or
is the Deep State too deep
uh
uh I always just vote for who I think is
gonna bring less war to the world and so
I hope he can end more of the wars again
he's asking if elections are real
oh yeah are the election like deal like
because uh because obviously oh yeah
obviously I I'm afraid to get suicided
so I have uh you better yeah I don't
think there's anybody from Hillary's
Camp here I might have seen one but so
but so so here's my question to you if
the left is going to cheat what tactic
do you think they're going to use I'll
give you guys two two options another
pandemic with Joe Biden and fauci the
CDC The Who they've all warned us a
second pandemic is coming or do you
think it's gonna be something even on a
broader scale like an alien invasion
which all we've all we've been hearing
about for the past three years is aliens
illegal alien not illegals actual aliens
from different planet what do you think
uh I think that they're going to use all
of them because they know how unpopular
their candidate is I well because mind
you he's not Joe Biden isn't even
campaigning he's not doing anything bro
okay here's here's another question Mark
Zuckerberg Elon Musk it's the fight
number one who do you think's gonna win
and number two do you think either of
them are aliens because there's a lot of
speculation where people like one is a
lizard and one's a reptilian and they're
gonna just expose themselves at the UFC
fight
I I want Elon to win yeah uh but I'm
rooting for Zuckerberg as I feel like
this is the opportunity the nerd never
gets the nerd I think the nerd and I was
going ever against so it's it's a
thrilling story no matter what about you
Jason I think Zuckerberg just turns up
his robot powers and wins really oh my
God yeah I have a feeling that elon's
just gonna get yoked and do that uh what
is it the what's that brain stuff that
he's talking about uh no neural link
okay okay so here's here's I want to
wrap up but no do you think and I'm
being genuine do you think Elon being
the savior of free speech because if you
think about bro spending 60 some billion
dollars to let us be able to see here
and talk the truth talk smack talk
whatever do you think that that's a
genuine thing that he's doing as as a
human being to give us a voice or do you
think he is a wolf in sheep's clothing
and he's using that to make people love
him to put the neural link because the
FDA proved that the day after
the day after he bought Twitter neural
link was approved by the FDA do you
think he's genuinely cares or do you
think it's a it's a wolf in sheep
clothing situation I I think he
genuinely cares and I think God has done
funnier things than you zelon musk in
the past so I think he genuinely cares
is trying to do what's right and also I
think he's once the neuro Link in
everybody's head okay uh to that last
thing 2020 for narrow Link in my head
though okay really really
amazing it's amazing I don't trust
anything whose technology saying that
technology is not inherently bad I don't
think so either but who's to say what
the hell program he could put in there
to kick your ass I'm afraid to even use
a Kindle I I want my books in my head so
I we have this is a disagreement that we
you're ready to sign up to have them
open up your brain CEO of a tech company
I can't just be I can't I have to act
like you're on the waiting you're on the
waiting list to get this put in
your brain yeah whatever it takes I get
it so uh so 2024 what's your prediction
who are you voting for Thomas Sowell
Thomas Soul really good
[Music]
okay well I just want someone that has
uh the taste of blood in his mouth yeah
and no one else has that oh God there's
Chum in the water there's Chum in the
water and he's there yeah you're just
not gonna there with no chance of
anybody else having the anger and rage
to do anything so Thomas you have to
pick number two you're going uh whoever
is running against Biden that's uh it
could be just a blob with just skin and
hair
all right guys well thank you guys for
being here I appreciate you guys and
what's say the name of the company it's
a lore
tvlor.tv subscriber free seven day trial
and start funding contents that aren't
gay I just I just rubbed your nipple by
the way too but so let me just okay
thank you guys peace
[Music]